you know what the one thing had a hard  time with saying for the longest time  you ready this is gonna sound weird had  a hard time saying I don't know weird  doesn't it we gotta we love saying I  know hey do you know what happened with  that one thing yeah I know I know I  heard about it do you know such-and-such  yeah of course I know I know who he is  have you watched at one movie I know I  think I did one time did you read this  book yeah I did I did so do you know  what happened I know and when we say I  know even though we don't know we're not  growing the day I started using the  magical words I don't know  I got smarter and wiser so today  practice saying I don't know  and notice how quickly you learn a thing  or two that you didn't know before